whether you love or hate Jamie Diamond
you got to know what this guy came up
from by the way this guy was an
assistant a personal assistant in 1982
for American Express working for Sandy
wild where Sandy eventually ends up
becoming the CEO of City this guy's an
assistant regular guy working for
another guy eventually whatever he
touches turns to Gold later on he gets
fired by Sandy wow and today CEO of a
company that processes ready 10 trillion
dollars a day in 170 currencies in 120
countries and named JP Morgan Chase is
the most systemically important Bank in
the world by G20 when we learn about
this man's come up what he's done you're
finally going to realize why so many
people behind closed doors want to see
this guy run for office so some people
wonder well you know is Jamie Rich how
rich is Jamie well let me just say when
it comes down to Jamie do you know what
he believes in a lot art do you know how
big his personal art collection is take
a wild guess 10 million 50 million 100
million 200 million come on Pat 900
million dollars here's a look into his
900 million dollar personal art
collection which has a hidden staircase
fake bookcases and a secret vault and
you know why because this guy
understands investments in alternative
assets and that's why today's sponsors
Masterworks for some of you guys that
are watching the same path did I count
by 900 million dollars worth of art I
got real doors I don't have fake doors
or fake bookcases I understand but
Masterworks makes it easy for you to
invest in a 10 million dollar piece of
art and just buy a piece of share of it
okay whether it's Banksy Warhol Picasso
doesn't matter that's what they do they
have nearly 750 000 users today when you
think about Contemporary Art versus
select assets during High inflation
periods above three percent here's what
it looks like gold does roughly 0.2
percent SMP that's 3.8 percent reach to
five percent emergent market equities
12.6 but Contemporary Art
23.2 percent during High inflation you
want to learn more click on the link
below to learn more about Masterworks if
you get value out of this video give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
but before we go into how he became the
CEO of the largest bank in the world the
most important Bank in the world how
does the story really begin this goes
all the way back to his grandfather when
he immigrated in 1921 and started a
successful career as a banker his father
was also a wealthy stock broker would
make diamond look at balance sheets and
earnings of a company then determine
what the stock price should be based on
the financials let's just say he's got
the right genetics so far and then also
it's fair to say that his family was
upper class during his childhood but
Diamond was very ambitious and wanted to
make his own fortune he was rejected by
his dream College Brown then he attended
Tufts instead which by the way is still
a great school but he was very angry
about the fact that brown said no to him
then Diamond applies to get transferred
to Princeton gets rejected again he
eventually ends up graduating at the top
of his class at Tufts and got accepted
into Harvard Business School and out of
Harvard he ends up graduating in the top
five percent of his class so you know
how sometimes a lot of these big
companies like we got to recruit that
kid coming out of Harvard he was number
one in his class that guy was number one
in Tufts that guy was number one in
brown he's one of those guys that
everybody wants to recruit so rather
than taking any of these offers he
decides to work for a family friend
named Sandy Weil for a third of what
everybody else offered him to make
meaning if others paid him 200 Grand a
Year Sandy could only pay him seventy
thousand dollars and he said no problem
I will work for you so so this is when
the duo Sandy and Diamond go on a nearly
a 20-year run to get and here's how to
get started while ends up selling his
company to American Express for 900
million dollars and gets hired as the
president and hires Jamie Diamond as his
personal assistant at American Express
while quit after a disagreement with the
company's board and Diamond followed him
out of loyalty even though wow said you
don't want to do this you just started a
family kind of stay here why go is going
to be probably risky for you so why
don't you stick around here and diamonds
like no no no I'm following your lead so
once wild knew he couldn't stop diamond
from following him he says look let's
start something here together then to
find a commercial Credit Company CCC
which gave credit to low-income
households while instructed Diamond to
analyze CCC Diamond eventually ends up
finding hidden value in the company CCC
had a low return on Equity four percent
while competitors had 15 percent return
on Equity Diamond realized that CCC has
a lot of assets that could be sold in
cost to be cut considered a company he
could turn around this next part is
pretty interesting they end up reaching
out to Warren Buffett for some money and
Warren Buffett says I'm not interested
after Warren Buffett said no they said
look we're going to use our own money
they end up using a significant portion
of their own money to buy 10 of CCC and
raise 850 million dollars from IPO they
sold enough of the company to obtain an
investment grade credit rating and while
made Diamond the CFO and he laid up 10
percent of ccc's employees on the first
day 18 Roe return on Equity after one
year of running the company this caused
the credit rating to increase eventually
when 1987 crash occurred CCC had a
healthier balance sheet than most
competitors so they began purchasing
distressed companies one of the
distressed companies they bought was
Primerica and then eventually all of
these companies together in 1998 turn
into Citigroup at the time the biggest
financial company in America so while
this is taking place Jamie Diamond's
aspirations was to eventually be the CEO
of Citigroup he doesn't become CEO he
does become the president but Jamie in
the back of his mind is like when am I
going to get my chance to be the CEO at
the same time something very interesting
happens Sandy's daughter gets hired to
work in diamonds Division and Diamond
had a major disagreement with wild while
Vanguard launched the first low-cost
Index Fund Jamie wanted to use the same
strategy and eventually wins the
argument Wild's daughter was responsible
for the low-cost Index Fund Division and
it was massively underperforming
compared to the competition Jamie
scrutinized her and ultimately refused
the promoter so while all the stuff is
taking place and Jamie's on track and
all of a sudden boom November 1998 he
decides not to promote Sandy says you're
fired and by the way
Jamie wasn't expecting this Jamie
thought for sure he's going to be your
CEO matter of fact both of them were
asked this question afterwards Jamie
Diamond says this impacted my net worth
but not self-wort and Sandy wow said I
fired Jaime Diamond because he wanted to
be CEO the problem was in 1999 he wanted
to be the CEO and I didn't want to
retire I regret that it came to that I
don't know what else could have been
done except for him to be more patient
so both of them give their own point of
view but at the end of the day he was
fired so imagine you're the guy coming
up you're the Superstar now you don't
have a job what do you do next but the
market knows this is a superstar this
guy's not gonna have a hard time finding
a job and he found a job very quickly
Jaime gets hired as the CEO of a
struggling bank one and here's what he
does year one ready he fires not 10
people not a hundred people not a
thousand people not ten thousand people
he fires 12 000 people year one can you
imagine hey guys Sandy yo fire Jamie
we're getting the
this is awesome guess what you're fired
12 000 people get fired and he cuts
executive compensation he took away
company cars 401K match and executive
bonuses gifts financial planning started
selling under performing parts of the
business took 4.4 billion dollars in
write downs and Loan loss Provisions
Bank One posted a yearly loss of 500
million dollars in 2000 but guess what
happened next the company stock starts
going up because Wall Street liked what
Jamie Diamond was doing and Diamond
prioritized a fortress balance sheet
more than anything else this was kind of
his philosophy lots of cash good
collateral treasuries and gold assets
with real value healthy amount of
Leverage ready to buy things cheap bank
one just a year later post profits ready
of 2.6 billion dollars it's obviously
the market is saying oh my God look at
this guy first we thought it was crazy
what are you doing firing all these
people executive people are leaving
worst guy to work for you never want to
work for a guy like this and then all of
a sudden the market says damn this guy
kind of knows what he's doing at the
same time Chase is struggling because
they had the scandal with Enron and
they're kind of trying to figure out a
way to figure this thing out and clean
it up JP Morgan merges with Bank One in
2004 because at once Diamond has a seal
can you imagine we will merge with you
but the main reason we're doing it
Beyond closer it's not telling anybody
we kind of want that guy to run the
whole company after the merger JP Morgan
is the second largest bank with
Citigroup at first now remember
Citigroup was where he is you know what
I'm saying Sandy and daughter and all
that other stuff so there's a point to
prove right there as well when Diamond
took control of JP Morgan he cut costs
reshape incentive structure started
building his Fortress balance sheet
immediately offloaded the toxic subprime
loans and meanwhile Citigroup complete
opposite end they're sitting there
saying hey man this this kind of
subprime stuff is very problem man we're
making a lot of money here this is great
this is looking so good until
2008 when a market hits Jamie knew this
was coming and it was going going to be
bad and he didn't want JP Morgan Chase
to have exposure to the moment he took
over Citigroup ends up losing you ready
18.72 billion dollars in 2008 the
company CEO Charles Prince was forced to
resign November 2008 Chase had the
smallest loss of all banks in 2008 with
only 1.2 billion dollars once again 1.2
compared to 18.72 that's a big
difference so at the same time when you
think about 2008 a lot of these
companies are going out of business bear
storms being one of them but bear
Stearns you know most companies can't
afford to buy this company so what
happens the government quickly
identified that JP Morgan was the only
Bank capable of absorbing bear Stearns
okay the treasury secretary Hank Paulson
begged Diamond to buy bear Stearns
Diamond offered to buy for two dollars a
share one year prior the stock was a
hundred and seventy dollars think about
this let's negotiate look Jamie a year
ago this thing was 100 we'll give it to
you for a deal you know maybe 40 bucks
maybe 30 bucks how about two dollars two
dollars yes I'm the only guy that can do
it you don't have another option
he's right they eventually end up buying
the company government sweetened to deal
with a 30 billion dollar to reduce
diamonds risk exposure Diamond never
acted like it was a luxury and said he
did it for the financial system but Wall
Street viewed it as a great deal for the
bank because it helped JPMorgan expand
into areas like Investment Banking and
Prime brokerage dealing now a few other
deals that either 2008 WAMU was the bank
like I was with Mama back in the days it
was the largest bank failure in U.S
history JP Morgan buys this company just
in o4 it's valued at 330 billion dollars
JP Morgan buys it for 1.9 billion
dollars Pennies on a dollar 2015. they
buy Instant at 2016 they buy we pay 2023
First Republic Bank failure resulted in
acquisition by JP Morgan bargain price
from the FDIC second largest bank
failure in U.S history so let me get
this straight the largest he buys the
second largest he buys because he's got
this Fortress of cash available to him
to make these types of decisions when
everything is cheap now there's
obviously a lot of different takeaways
from this there's a good bad in the ugly
how could you how could you build up
this guy haven't you seen a story about
you know him being linked with you know
Epstein and JP Morgan Bank involved with
what they did how about the fact that
during the time of him being the CEO of
the company that paid nearly 35 billion
dollars in fines how can we recognize
somebody like this that they've had to
pay these types of fines these are real
numbers by the way and they're valid
points but here's what I'm want you to
think about here his leadership style
let's take the best and I'll tell you
why some people want this guy to run for
office number one there's something that
he was famous for saying he said if
there's a problem you tell me about it's
our problem if there's a problem you
don't tell me about it's your problem
believe me you don't want to have a
problem which means if something's not
working talk about it with me and let's
process it if you don't bring it up to
me you best fix it or else you're fired
that's my interpretation of how he runs
the company number two involved in all
aspects of the business from top to
bottom using highly efficient meetings
with agendas an action pointer to be
addressed always carry it around a sheet
of paper with a topic needed to be
addressed encourages transparency and
direct feedback from all employees once
constant feedback from the people who
directly deal with the customers and
number one business philosophy was
maintained The Fortress balance sheet
his friends say that he doesn't do much
aside from run the business this guy is
maniacal about running a company so now
he gives a speech I'm going to play it
for you I want you to watch and tell me
what you think about this here's Jamie
Diamond the other way around America has
the best hand ever dealt of any country
on this planet today ever
okay and Americans don't fully
appreciate what I'm about to say we have
peaceful wonderful Neighbors in Canada
and Mexico
we've got the biggest military barriers
ever built called the Atlantic and the
Pacific
we have all the food water and energy we
will ever need
okay we have the best military on the
planet and we will for as long as we
have the best economy and if you're a
liberal listen closely to me in that one
okay because the Chinese would love to
have our economy we have the best
universities on the planet they're great
ones elsewhere but these are the best we
still educate uh you know most of most
of the kids who start businesses around
the world we have a rule of law which is
exceptional if you don't believe me and
we talk about Britain Brazil Russia and
the Venezuela Argentina uh China India
believe me it's not quite there we have
a magnificent work ethic we have
Innovation from the core of our bones
you can ask anyone in this room what can
you do to be more productive ask your
assistance Factory floors we do it it's
not just the Steve Jobs it's the broad
death we're the wise and deepest
financial markets the world's ever seen
okay and if you I just made a list of
these things and maybe I missed
something it's extraordinary
it's extraordinary and we have it today
yes we have problems but you know when I
hear people down if you travel around
the world I mean get an airplane travel
around the world and go to all these
other countries and tell me what you
think so look whether you like him or
not you know you hear a message like
that of somebody talking about how much
they love America I respect it but when
I see Putin selling Russia I respect the
fact that someone's got that kind of
pride in their own country I don't like
the fact that a lot of Americans want to
bash America finally we got some leaders
that are saying great things about their
own country and they're proud you want
to hear more of that so I like that part
in regards to you being uncomfortable
with some of the business dealings or
whatever he's done 38 billion dollars
and fines totally get it you can talk
about that as a bank when you're around
for as long as this guy's been around
and the bank is as big as it is it's
going to have some weird customers 2013
they cut ties with Epstein you can read
more about it and say I don't like this
this is the reason why I would never
want a guy like this to run which you
can respect about a guy like this is a
few things one he chose the right person
to run with for 16 years and he became
that person's number number one flag
carrier Sandy wild you got to give him
credit for running with that guy being
loyal and look what happened to his
career Sandy won he won he loved the
fact that he's running with somebody
that's super hungry Sandy loved the fact
that he's got a guy that's willing to go
out there and do the work what a great
partnership obviously sometimes you
bring a daughter in you don't want to
promote that can be kind of Technical
and you know you know sensitive it is
what it is that's one part lasts a long
time has a philosophy stays clear to it
is about cash calculated risk there's a
lot of things to be said about this and
his story is a story that somebody right
now working at whatever position you're
at right now if you have the ambition
you're working behind closed doors to
improve yourself eventually one day you
can do something big where people will
say I never thought he would be there I
never thought you would be at a position
like this because no matter how much
people laugh at you only one person
knows how determined you are about your
vision and that's you so there's a
reason why guys like Ackman Bill Ackman
and all these other guys saying it's a
shame game this guy's not running so
obviously there's a lot of other bills
out there that want to see a guy like
this run you know one thing about Jamie
he's always very diplomatic in the way
he answers I've spent some time with you
know uh Goldman Sachs folks similar
he'll say stuff like hey Jamie are you
Republican or Democrat well listen you
know I'm a Democrat of my heart but I'm
a republican in my brain it's kind of
like gives those types of answers like
oh should I get upset at him or not
because he knows he's got Democratic
clients and Republican but eventually if
this guy decides to run he's got to
choose one party to be a part of we're
going to see what's going to happen what
a story to go from an assistant to all
of a sudden you're running the biggest
bank in the world you got to give him
credit for that part if you got value
out of this video I got another one I
want you to watch on generational wealth
what a story on Vanderbilt's Rothschild
Medici family what these guys did with
their money what did they do right and
what did they do wrong if you've never
seen a click here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye
foreign
[Music]